can I ask you to put your pens down and
look up for a minute not gonna show you
the whole answer yet but I see you
writhing in pain and I'm gonna try and
nudge you a little bit in the right
direction and make sure we're all on the
same page and then you still have a bit
of work to do to think about how to
actually answer the question okay now
part of what you're all struggling with
and it's really interesting I don't
think I've seen the same diagram on any
of the twenty plus pages that you have
here in the room everyone's is slightly
different and one of the reasons why
you've all come up with different
diagrams off of the same question right
is that there is sufficient information
in this question but there are many
different ways to represent it and in
fact that's going to be key to the way
that we solve it I will point out some
ways are better than others okay so when
you think about for example the first
couple of parts here that say your
towers built on flat ground three
tourists are observing the tower and
then in the third line it starts to talk
about bearings right so this is
information about what's happening on
the ground level from the bird's eye
view if you like okay and then they talk
about north they talked about East and
so on but then in the immediate next
line this is what makes it
three-dimensional right in the immediate
next slide
rather than we have bearings they talk
about angles of elevation so we
introduced this up-down aspect to things
right now you can draw one diagram which
encapsulates all of it I am actually
going to use a second diagram by the end
of it but here's how I'm going to set
about if you want to if you're looking
at your diagram you're like I have no
idea if this is on the right track and
if you've got a bad diagram you already
have no way to interpret like what's the
thing I'm trying to work toward right
I'm gonna show you a diagram you don't
have to use this exact one but I think
it captures all the information that we
need here's the tower the first thing
that it took us about is this a B and C
and a is due north now because I've
drawn the tower as an object with height
I would normally indicate north is up on
my page but that's not going to be very
helpful for me on this particular way of
doing it so what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to imagine this in three
dimensions and I'm gonna have North sort
of going off into the distance like so
there it is going that way
and I'm gonna place a somewhere on this
line it's do you know if I don't know
how far but that's part of the question
okay then we talk about B and C C is due
east now it doesn't say due east of what
but hopefully there's enough of a clue
in that sentence that tells you what
it's due east of what do you think C is
due east of hmm read the sentence again
this is so important right a is due
north of the tower C is due east of the
tower is clearly what's implied it's so
sneaky little tiny words or phrases and
obviously you'd get a whole different
diagram if you said C was due east of a
different diagram altogether it is due
east of the tower now because I'm trying
to represent three dimensions here I'm
gonna have East going off in that
direction okay now if you look at it as
a whiteboard right this angle here is
not ninety degrees but I want it to be
ninety degrees so I'm looking at this
sort of isometrically if you like so I'm
gonna play C where did I place it before
I think roughly here okay you'll see it
later on why I didn't use all of this
space that I drew there okay a C and
then they talked about what the right
color here it is they talked about B
being between a and C on their line of
sight now admittedly that's a phrase we
don't use very frequently but it kind of
tells you what it means right if a was
to look at C or C was to look at a on
that line of sight let's draw it in on
that line of sight B is somewhere on
there right somewhere in the middle we
don't know where it is but it's gonna be
somewhere on there I'm gonna place it
roughly here okay so I think we've
captured all of the flat ground
information so far are you okay with
that Tower a B and C now we need to
introduce some vertical entities right
and you can see or you'll say you're
about to see why I've chosen the colors
that I have we're gonna have triangles
of plenty flying around this thing we
already have more than one here but I'm
going to use the colors so that I can
distinguish the triangles from each
other so they're talking about a and
angle of elevation to the top of the
tower right so this is something on the
ground and the angle elevation is going
to go up like so and from memory I think
that's 26 degrees 26 so if you like I've
got my red triangle which is all to do
with a and the tower then the next one I
think they give us is about be right
there just doing it respectively so a B
and C so from being through the tower I
actually missing a line I never a ground
line for B because all angles of
elevation as well as angles of
depression they're all measured from the
horizontal right so this is the
horizontal along the ground from B to
the tower and then he looks up or she
looks up and that gives me the 28 yeah
so I've got an orange triangle here
which is all about B and the tower and
then a complete I'm going to complete it
here there we go this is my angle of
elevation from C and it's my 30 degrees
okay now there's just one last thing
whoopsie-daisy I'm so uncoordinated
there's one last thing that we need
that's the actual question what are they
actually asking for look carefully
bearing of B from from the tower from
the tower okay now because a bearing is
it's a flat ground question right so I'm
going to go down on the ground here the
bearing to B we usually measure this
from north right well handily I already
have north on my diagram there it is
okay so from north I'm going to turn
clockwise to get to B that's the angle
that I'm after okay so I'm gonna pause
there I haven't done any work in
actually like calculating any of the
extra information I need but this is the
diagram I'm going to use it's not the
only one it starts to get confusing when
I put in some of the information we're
going to determine onto this diagram
it's already very busy it's gonna get
even busier but if you didn't if you
were struggling like there's my diagram
right I don't know I could tell you the
confidence this diagram has all the
information on it that the question has
and it's represented in a consistent way
so I'm gonna let you now from there use
some of the trigonometry that you know
and see where you can get from there